l'Amazonie un joyau mondial la
biodiversité plus qu'une forêt c'est une
pharmacie
25% de nos médicaments sont issus des
plantes tropicales mais surtout
l'Amazonie et notre climatiseur parce
qu'elle capte le carbone qui réchauffe
l'atmosphère
pourtant on a rasé l'équivalent de la
tête de la France en seulement 50 ans et
passe en conséquence l'Amazonie crée ses
propres nuages plus on abat des arbres
plus les sécheresses sont fréquentes et
plus le reste de la forêt dégrade c'est
un cercle vicieux
des scientifiques sonnent l'alarme sur
le point de non retour si on détruit
encore 10% de sa surface la forêt
tropicale deviendra une savane aride des
milliers d'espèces vont périr
le climat va se détraquer l'Amazonie
n'est pas la seule victime toute la
planète sera touchée